oh no I don't know anything about the
essential very different today from
yesterday yeah not there today for sure
you're not gonna forget this week in a
rush no that's for sure tell us how you
feeling when you woke up this morning
begging i did yesterday morning less for
sure so you know and he'll their life
now a huge amount of support yeah people
have been fantastic taught them football
put you nose the Chairman everybody's
giving great support the family and
everybody so you know you know it was a
case that should never been brought to
court in the first place to be honest we
and you know when mr. leave he gave me
the job for years ago he looked it
before he appointed me obviously and
even realize it was a case they had no
substance to it so what he wouldn't give
me the job at Tottenham so it's past us
now we look forward and look to the
future and Harry just before you go
obviously the singing job it's a long
time and I've never I'm not not able for
about it I've got a job to do got big
game sadly for Tottenham so you know
Tottenham is talking with my focus you
know so but I better go anyway and you
know if you give us a bit of peace I'm
not I won't be coming back and my wife's
not feeling too great to be honest with
yourself all right it's not your
question long time no see do you want
mater yeah it's been a tricky 24 hours
for you yeah I've been a tricky five
years has been dragging on for that
hanging over 25 years thousands demand
Rick you know the man who paid hundred
million pound in income tax in that
period is he go joy is he going to go
out and try to suddenly safe pain about
between 20 and 30 thousand pound of
income tax you know you know it's
ridiculous how did you react when you
heard the Fabio news what I was shocked
you know I'm surprised I didn't expect
that to happen we
leaving a summer but I didn't expect you
to happen now and what are your thoughts
about everybody is tipping you are you
interested I listen I honestly I've just
got to get on top numbers like you know
they've been fantastic to me tottenham
people and look at the fans last week we
can game it was incredible the reception
they gave me so I wouldn't be right to
them to even focus anything else but
taught them that's my only interest is
at Tottenham Hotspurs would you like to
get involved at all helping the FA out
with the euros I've never thought about
it you know they'll make whatever
decision they want to make and I'm sure
it actually would be the right decision
for the country but as I say I'm just my
focus is all on top of them thank you
thank you glad have a good day